the way um I know I know German
colleagues are feeling a little bit
excited uh but if you could if you could
take your if you could take your seats
uh first of all could I take the
adoption of the agenda do I take that as
adopted okay that's fine and approval of
the minutes of the 5th of September may
I take those as approved as usual you've
all had them thank you very much now
we've got some chairs announced ments
which we can get out of the way before
the monetary dialogue first of all
there's the AFCO report on multi-tier
governance and we've I'd like to report
on the long-standing issue regarding
that report I've expressed several times
econ's concerns on the scope of the AFCO
report in so far as it could cover
issues on emu and in particular on
banking Union which the econ committee
is currently discussing has recently
discussing or is in the process of
negotiating for example SSM SRM uh brrd
and dgs to uh give you a few sets of
initials on the 4th of September chair
Cassini confirmed to me the AFCO
committee's preparedness to treat the
suggestions in the opinion adopted by
econ as if the application of rule 50
were granted for Part D of the draft res
resolution from AFCO Part D covers the
matters of econ exclusive competence and
econ will deliver its opinion for its
inclusion in the AFCO final report
without a vote so that means we vote but
then the AFCO committee have to accept
what we have voted accordingly as well
the AFCO recital an and amendments uh
outside Part D which are inconsistent or
incompatible with the econ opinion
opinion that Covers Part D uh should not
be put to the vote uh following informal
further contacts between the AFCO and
econ rapporteurs econ is now planning to
vote on the 17th of October which I
understand is a date that also meets and
is agreeable with the AFCO committee so
that looks like that we have a
satisfactory uh outcome there
forthcoming simplified procedures that's
article 46 of the rules of procedures
econ coordinators decided on the 10th of
September that the simplified procedure
without amendments should be applied to
the following files the EU France
agreement concerning the application of
the collectivity of St bartholomy of
Union legislation on the taxation of
savings and administrative cooperation
in the field of Taxation uh the
rapporter is uh Mr NAS from the EP p and
the second one amending directives um
2,612 EC and 2008 118 EC as regards the
French outermost regions in particular
uh of uh mayot uh the rapporter for that
is Mr kazer uh and a brief exchange of
views and vote is scheduled for the 21st
of October we are also expected to vote
on a quick fix uh a second Quick Fix on
omnibus 2 directive that's concerning
the solvency 2 matters on the same date
for its adoption in plenary in November
that all of course depends upon the
commission delivering in time uh which
we expect on the 2nd of October rule 51
The Joint econ libbe issue on anti-money
laundering directive and funds transfer
regulation as an announced last week the
anti-money laundering directive and
funds transfer regulation will be dealt
with under rule 51 that means a joint
committee uh sitting together of econ
and libe and in agreement with the uh
four coor because there's two for each
committee and there are two uh there are
two issues the tentative calendar has
been set as follows presentation of the
draft report Wednesday 6th of November
amendments deadline will be Friday the
15th of November presentation of
amendments uh Thursday the 5th of
December uh aiming to vote on the Monday
or Tuesday 20th or 21st of
January and finally update on trialogues
um a third trialogue on the bank
recovery and resolution directive was
held on the 18th of September revised
texts on scope resolution authorities
and special management were discussed
the meeting held F exchanges on the
issue of the home host uh and EBA powers
and on conditions for resolution that is
triggers the next trialogue is on the 26
of September and there's further offline
work on nonp papers and exchanges of uh
ideas and texts going on in between so
with that we can now have a a suspension
for a few minutes uh and I'll go and uh
meet uh Mario and bring him into
committee thank
you
e
for
that's
than
you
winding
okay we we we will start if the uh
photographers can at least get keep out
of the view of of members that would be
appreciated I've had a private little
exchange with Mario and for those of you
who follow Twitter I can tell you he did
ask for an ft on the this morning
contrary to the allegation that he only
asked for a sports newspaper and they
had neither so I'm not sure which
airline it was but uh they didn't have
an ft but I'm sure you read it the night
before like the rest of us anyway Mario
nice to to welcome you to committee um
and you'll present the ecb's P
perspective on economic and uh monetary
developments and then we'll go to the
usual questions and answers with members
it's five minute slots remember members
so the the less time you use the more
chance you have of coming back for a a
follow-up question which are often uh
the ones that will be harder for Mario
to answer um so thank you for that and
the floor is
yours thank you Madame chair honorable
members of the committee on economic and
monetary
Affairs it's it's a pleasure for me to
be back with your committee shortly
after the important vote of your
assembly on the SSM
regulation this vote has been preceded
by intense interaction on the
interinstitutional agreement on
accountability and
transparency and I would like to thank
president Schulz your committee and the
negotiating team for the commitment to a
successful establishment of the
SSM our two institutions share a common
interest in a Swift and effective
implementation of the banking
Union the draft interinstitutional
agreement ensures high standards of
transparency and
accountability while safeguarding the
protection of confidential
information we will continue working
with a similar constructive spirit in
the months ahead and hope that this will
allow a swift setup of the supervisory
board today I will first review recent
economic and monetary developments in
the Euro
area I will then address the two topics
that you have selected for our
discussion the impact of our nonstandard
measures and the new tasks of the ECB in
the reformed European monetary Union
architecture
since our meeting in July we have
received positive data for the Euro area
economy following six quarters of
negative output growth Euro areal GDP
Rose by
0.3% quarter on quarter in the second
quarter of
2013 measures of confidence and surveys
of production have given some support to
the view that Euro area economic
activity should continue its slow
recovery in the current quarter despite
weak production data for
July looking forward economic activity
should benefit from a gradual
Improvement in domestic demand supported
by the ecb's accommodative monetary
policy
stance and strengthening external demand
for Euro area exports
however unemployment in the Euro area
remains far too high and the recovery
will need to be firmly
established annual Euro area inflation
declined by declined to
1.3% in August
2013 down from
1.6% in
July underly price pressures are
expected to remain
subdued reflecting the broad based
weakness in aggregate demand and the
modest pace of
recovery medium to long-term inflation
expectations continue to be firmly
anchored in line with price
stability the risks to the outlook for
Price developments are expected to be
still broadly balanced over the medium
term
monetary and in particular credit
Dynamics remain
subdued the annual rate of change of
loans to the private sector and notably
to firms weakened further in
July weak loan Dynamics continue to
reflect the current stage of the
business cycle but also heightened
credit risk and the ongoing adjustments
in the balance sheets of borrowers and
land
the significant Improvement in the
funding situation of banks since the
summer of
2012 has not yet fed through into higher
credit
provision against this background the
governing Council has pledged to
maintain monetary policy accommoda for
as long as
necessary in order to reaffirm and
clarify this conditional pledge in a
context of volatile money market
interest rates the ECB has introduced
forward guidance in
July stating that it expects the key ECB
interest rates to remain at present or
lower levels for an extended period of
time this expectation which has has been
reconfirmed in August and in
September is based on a subdued outlook
for inflation extending into the medium
term given the broad-based weakness in
the economy and subdued monetary
Dynamics we will maintain the degree of
monetary accommodation warranted by the
outlook for Price stability and aim at
promoting stable money market conditions
to ensure an adequate transmission of
monetary policy to the financing
conditions in the broader economy it is
essential that effective measures be
taken to further reduce fragmentation of
Euro Area Credit markets and to
strengthen the resilience of banks where
needed monetary policy contributes to
these objectives but it can only address
impairments in transm
in so far as they are not related to
more structural
barriers by giving unlimited access to
Central Bank refinancing against
adequate
collateral our no standard measures have
been pivotal in relieving Bank funding
stress the collateral framework has been
adjusted as necessary to ensure
continued adequate risk protection for
the ecb's balance sheet while at the
same time promoting
transparency for example in markets for
structured Finance
products ensuring that solvent Banks
remain liquid has contributed to
avoiding an Abrupt deleveraging which
would have deeply damaged the
economy the outright monetary
transactions omts announced a year ago
have prevented risks of destructive
scenarios with potentially severe
challenges for Price stability in the
Euro
area omts serve as a fully effective
back stop within the ecb's Mandate and
under formal conditionality so as to
preserve the appropriate incentives for
governments to ensure fiscal s solvency
and adopt those structural policies that
can put the economy on a sustainable
path over the past 12 months confidence
in the Euro area has
returned as a consequence fragmentation
in Euro area funding markets has been
receding this Improvement owes not only
to the ecb's no standard measures but
also to progress by governments in
improving the Euro area governance and
in pursuing reform
agendas deposit outflows from stressed
countries have been
reversed Market access for banks has
improved Reliance on ECB funding support
has been steadily
declining these improvements are
reflected primarily in the ongoing
advanc repayments of funds by several
Banks which had borrowed from the ECB
under the two threeyear longer term
refinancing
operations while repayment of Central
Bank credit is cly a sign of
normalization the resulting reduction in
excess liquidity can reinforce upward
pressures on term money market rates
and we will remain particularly
attentive to the implications that these
developments may have for the stance of
monetary
policy let me finally address the tasks
of the ECB in the reformed European
monetary Union
architecture the master setup has been
substantially strengthened since the
start of the crisis
Europe has reinforced fiscal and
macroeconomic
surveillance created a permanent crisis
management mechanism the
esm and has improved its institutional
framework it is moving swiftly towards
the single supervisory mechanism for
banks in the Euro
area a key priority of the agenda for
the last quarter of
2013 is to com complement it by a single
resolution Authority and a single
resolution fund as proposed by the
European
commission the ECB strongly supports the
envisaged timeline for the establishment
of the SRM by January 1st
2015 which adequately reflects the
urgency let me make a few remarks on the
specific role of the ECB in the progress
towards a fully fledged banking
Union already in 2010 with the decisive
contribution of your
institution the ESRB was created to
oversee macroprudential risks in the
financial system as a
whole the ECB ensures the Secretariat
and thereby provides support to the
SRB this year a further reaching step is
being made with the imminent launch of
the single supervisory
mechanism the ECB is fully committed to
assume its new
responsibilities and to discharge
accountability
accordingly Preparatory work has started
in order to ensure that the new tasks
are performed at the highest level of
Effectiveness and profession
ISM while synergies between the new
supervisory and existing monetary policy
functions exist the ECB will strictly
respect the principle of separation
between monetary policy and banking
supervision as foreseen by the SSM
regulation such separation will ensure
that the ECB will continue to fulfill
its primary Mandate of price stability
in complete Independence in line with
the
treaty the effective separation of
monetary policy and Bank supervision
decisions will be implemented both at
the decision making level and at the
technical staff level a separate
supervisory board will be created to
draft and enforce
decisions furthermore the liberations of
the governing Council on supervisor
matters will be strictly separated from
monetary policy
decisions this separation between the
two tasks will be underpinned by
separate agendas and
meetings finally let me say a few words
on the involvement of the ECB in the
troa back in 2010 we were asked by the
council to provide our technical
expertise to the design and monitoring
of EU IMF financial assistance
programs in the meantime the ECB has
been allocated a number of specific
tasks by the esm treaty and EU secondary
legislation we act in liazon with the
commission to provide technical advice
based on our
expertise as we have done in the past we
remain ready to share our view views on
the situation in program countries with
the European Parliament and explain the
advice provided as part of the
troa however it is important to recall
that the Euro group is the body which
actually decides whether to Grant
financial assistance and under which
terms thank you for your attention and
now looking forward to your
questions thank you very much thank you
[Applause]
um and and thank you very much for your
willingness to uh be as transparent as
you can on issues relating to the troa
that is something that concerns this
committee uh and of course it's not
something that we can uh manage to
achieve in a public sense uh Visa the
IMF so the fact that we can with the ECB
uh is is very welcome um we can move
straight ahead I think to the to the
questions first for the p p Jean Paul
GES to say thank
you I could put a topical question to
you but it's perhaps a little early in
the day to ask you what the possible
consequences of Chancellor merkel's
re-election in Germany may be as we wait
for her to put a new question her new
government together we should perhaps um
hang far on that
question now may I just say that
Parliament
welcomes
the interinstitutional agreement which
will ensure greater
transparency for the wording of your
supervisory functions or or be it with
the necessary Provisions for
confidentiality but you're now moving
into the more difficult period of
actually implementing these
procedures they look um promising on
paper
for the ECB and the
asmb you both would be covered you
talked about the need for a
watertight Great Wall of China between
the banking and supervisory board
functions could I ask you about the
precise time frame for the
implementation setting up the
supervisory boards given that this is
vital if the banking Union is actually
to become a practical
[Music]
reality thank you um let me say let me
take your question as a broader question
asking for what's the state of our
Preparatory work for the
SSM and um let me just say say that uh
we are watching with uh some degree of
satisfaction that fastest sustained
progress is being made towards the ECB
Readiness to assume its tasks under the
SSM
regulation ECB internal preparations are
well
underway and um progress to date has
been fostered by the close cooperation
between the ECB and the national
supervisors
we have uh set up specific structures
for preparing the
SSM we have the high level group and the
task force and
supervision a number of work streams
comprising of senior experts from the
national authorities and the ECB have
been established to conduct the
Preparatory
work in addition to facilitate this
Preparatory phase a total of 78 people
have have been seconded costree from the
national supervisory authorities to the
ECB there are four key areas where this
significant progress has been made let
me just list the areas and then later on
I may get into some sort of Greater
detail the first key area is the
development of the supervisory
manual the second important area is the
supervisory
reporting the third key area is the
development of the super the SSM
framework
regulation a fourth important area is
the Preparatory work to date on the
comprehensive assessment including a
balance sheet assessment of all banks
supervised directly about 130 banking
groups covering 85% of Euro Area Bank
assets then we have this this assessment
is B on is based on three pillars a risk
ass assessment a balance sheet
assessment and a stress
test let me say finally something on the
time
frame significant progress achieved in
recent
months dues owes a lot to uh the uh hard
work of the ECB and as I said also the
national
supervisors so the time frame foresees
the establishment of the SSM by within
the um within the schedule that has been
Always foreseen by the regulation namely
one year uh since the approval of the of
the
legislation and we will report to the
European Parliament about the progress
that we'll be making through a quarterly
report which is also going to be sent to
the European Council and to the
commission thank
you thank you um oh right actually I've
got a little note here from adula which
now says that we are aiming for a
possible vote in plenary in December on
the appointment of the SSM chair and
vice chair if we can um all get the
procedures uh done in time so that would
be uh good to get us on our way uh now
for the snd Alisa
Ferrera thank you
chair Sor dragi I'm
going Sharon can you stop the clock
please thank
[Laughter]
you Mr dragy it's a great pleasure to
see you here I'd like to welcome you
once
again
now as I've said on previous occasions
I'd like to thank you for uh the
European Central Bank for uh the work
that you've made to uh uh try and save
the Euro with the omts but the European
Central Bank is also part of the troa
and that's a very uh difficult model in
the case of a country like Portugal
Portugal has basically followed the uh
pretty much everything that was uh
recommended and they ended up with
pretty much a recession that was twice
as bad as What was forecast with
historically unprecedented
unemployment and a debt that's uh a huge
proportion of GDP
sovereign
debt is uh still at rates above 7% so
there are signs of recovery but it's
still too weak and too slow so as a
member of the troa
and as a the issue of the omts what can
you tell us about the future what can
you tell a country like
Portugal my second question is on the
role of the Central Bank as a a single
supervisor well I've got two small
questions for you the
first is on the starting uh
functioning so and when you're looking
at the asset quality
review how can you do that without
having a resolution mechanism in place
first and the second small question is
on the uh uh single resolution fund
which I'm the raor for
this fund is going to be funded by the
bank over 10 to 14 years how can this be
funded without a common back
stop basically some way to provide
credit when
necessary this credit would have to be
available from the moment when this uh
uh fund entered into
functioning so otherwise I think that
success might be at stake thank
you thank you
you
um on on um your question on
Portugal the uh we we are seeing as you
said the first signs of a
recovery on uh on the fiscal front it's
quite important what I always say is
that countries should not
unravel the progress they've made on
fiscal
consolidation so I don't think now it's
the time to uh speak for
extensions simply to continue now having
said that fiscal consolidation and here
I repeat something I've said many times
ought to be growth friendly which means
lower current
expenditure and less use of
Taxation third there should be full
implementation of structural reforms
some countries need to do structural
reforms mostly in the uh realm of
product uh and services markets and
competition other countries need to do
it first in the labor market but
continuation of structural reforms is
absolutely
essential to sustain the recovery to
sustain the red addressment of
imbalances across
countries now in the case of Portugal
there's also much to do in the real of
privatizations and this also something
is an area to to keep in mind
but I would say that actually the the
the recent history of shows
that even that even the slightest signs
of unraveling progress on fiscal
consolidation cause markets to react
brutally you've seen the spreads the
spreads jumped at the minimum sign that
something could go wrong and they went
back as fast as they had gone up so it's
h it's not something that we the that we
can simply forget Market discipline is
there and will stay there and we have to
take that into account in what we
do
the second point is how can we make an
asset quality think the second question
was how can we make an asset quality
review without an SRM in place well
first of all we still think that the SRM
should be in place by the time the ECB
will take up its tasks so that uh we we
have to uh assign
ourselves uh a pretty tight uh schedule
for approving the
SRM but all in all we have to use in
this first
stage mostly if actually only National
back stops so that's I'm going to say
more about that the for the asset
quality review and the stress test to be
credible we'll have to have National
back stops in
place the ECB will do its asset quality
review in the process that we can
discuss later in the way that we can
discuss later and can reach its results
and the SRM if it's there in place it's
better if it's not there in place it
will be up to the National authorities
to do and carry out this which is
suboptimal of
course finally your point about um uh
about what's going to back stop the SRM
while the funding progress let me say
that the uh 10 years as a Time Horizon
the ECB thinks it's not ambitious enough
it's too long a period of time
and I also agree with you that uh in the
meantime there should be some back stop
some credit line and it's not going to
be a transfer because it's going to be
recouped with the industry and
refunded but certainly it should be
there thank
you thank you very much now for Aldi
Sy good afternoon Mr President and
welcome the last part of your speech uh
was
intriguing do you intend
to slowly and carefully withdraw from
the troa I find it very interesting that
you said that we would provide technical
expertise provide technical advice the
advice provided as part of the tryco and
you said it's the Euro group that takes
decisions and this is an important issue
for citizens who decides on measures
taken by the troa are you just an
advisor
or does the troa uh which is an entity
that has no legal basis in the treaties
does that take the decisions and if it's
the Euro group to whom is the Euro group
accountable thank
you with the beginning of the
crisis I would say all actors suggested
that the troa be formed and the ECB as
uh
fully and uh at the best of its
competence provided with its own advice
and
expertise both governments this
institution the Euro group the
commission the
IMF we view this role as a
lasting as long as this crisis goes
on but certainly in the long term we
don't view the ECB as part of the
tro so that is the
answer but in this case who is deciding
what can I tell to the people who tell
me just you in the long term but when
will be the crisis over and when can we
decide that someone else is deciding not
just giving advise yes indeed the troa
doesn't decide it's the Euro group that
decides because the Euro group that
decides to finance the programs the
programs are being financed using
National budgets with national
contributions it's National taxpayers
that are being asked to pay taxes for
these programs so it's the Euro group
that is the
political institution let's call it this
way that decides on the programs the
troa has at least as far as the ECB is
concerned and advisory
role and the Euro group may or may not
accept advice uh let's go on to the did
you want to come back anymore Sylvie did
you want to come back
anymore Mr President but when I discuss
with a group of children I don't know
who is responsible for the mess in the
house and this is a little bit the same
feeling okay that's it thank well I like
you call the Euro group a a group of
children I mean
they'd be
[Laughter]
flattered oh dear yes okay um I I I
refer back to my previous comment right
now for the ECR uh deran
eping thank you m pres Madam president
the fed the Federal Reserve decided not
yet to reduce the pace of its quantitive
easing purchases it would instead wait
for more signs of sustained economic
progress before proceeding with tapering
now my question concerns the ECB
equivalent of quantitative easing in
late 201 the ECB started the ltro
program it provided roughly 1 trillion
Euro in emergency threeyear loans to
hundreds of European banks at low rates
with low Coller low collateral standards
earlier this month the EB's money market
contact group called for a renewal of
the LT loans as the W Street Journal
reported yesterday Mr leanan was quoted
in the the paper well known to you Corel
de laera as saying that the ECB is ready
to boost liquidity in the credit Market
by issuing another long-term loan if
necessary now the question is can you
comment on the recommendations of the
ecb's money market contact group and on
Mr lean's statement will the ECB launch
a new round of LT loans and under what
circumstances and it seems I've got the
impression that you are not tapering
anytime soon thank
you thank you your impression is
right um but let me say something on
ltro uh the uh overall total voluntary
repayments in both 3 years LT as of
September 10th stood at
331 billion e that correspond to
63.5% of the net liquidity injection at
the
beginning
now we have to
uh this is on one hand is a good sign
because it shows that banks are less
dependent on ECB financing and they can
actually Finance themselves either
through the market or via deposits or
exchanging trade credit lines between
each
other on the other hand markets watch
this uh quantity called excess liquidity
and may react increasing short-term
money market rates we have reacted to
this issu in our own forward guidance
which is different from the one in us
and in in UK and in
Japan but also we are ready to use any
instrument including another LT if
needed to maintain the short-term money
markets at the level that it's warranted
by our assessment of inflation in the
medium
term thank
you did you want to come back no no okay
in that case we can move on to the
greens uh Sven
gigal well welcome president uh and uh
just I have a couple of questions
concerning the state of
implementation of the single supervisory
mechanism uh first uh the regulation
foresees strict uh separation between
monetary and uh supervisory policy you
were reconfirming this principle here in
very clear words may I therefore ask
whether there will be now starting
basically as of today meetings of the
supervisory body in the as in in the ECB
in order to ensure that uh there is real
separation also in the decision making
or do you intend to wait until the chair
and vice chair have been formally
approved second will there be SE clearly
separate career path inside of the ECB
so that staff on the supervisory side
can dare to uh take decisions which
might not be liked by the monetary side
third uh the regulation foresees strict
uh um Quality through asset balance
sheet tests sorry asset tests and
balance sheet tests could you confirm uh
that whether uh government bonds will be
stressed in the consequence of this
exercise and lastly uh can you comment
whether the ECB will make sure that the
balance sheet assessments uh on the
national level will not be done Alone by
national supervisors but also by
independent experts to control not only
at the top level at the ECB but also in
the construction of the balance sheet
that the results will be free from
conflict of interest thank
you thank
you let me uh restate that uh the
separation principle is
fully uh fully
enforced that uh both are our own
experience at the ECB but
also for those central banks that have
uh supervisory competence as well uh
they had the longstanding
experience that the two functions can be
carried out without infringing one upon
another the um your one of your
questions was about yes I can confirm
that the um asset quality review and the
balance sheet assessment will be done by
the ECB by the national
supervisors by Third parties supervisors
in other words we do expect
collaboration from say other part other
member country
supervisors each other and by private
sector
independent consultants and this is a
requirement for all member states yes
indeed
indeed so there will be there will
be a series of uh Consultants which will
there will be a series of tenders that
they will through which they will hire
the Consultants at National level we
also launched a tender for hiring a
private sector consultant in the ECB by
the way so uh we you see more
generally the the asset quality review
and the balance sheet assessments are
useful only if they are
credible and to this extent we should do
everything that's necessary that's our
conviction otherwise they're going to be
completely useless if not
counterproductive so I think one one of
the one of the uh one of the things one
of the outcomes that we do expect from
these uh from these test from the asset
quality review from the balance sheet
assessment from the risk
assessment is to dispel this fog that
Lies Over Banks balance sheets in the
Euro area and in
Europe uh the I think to to to some
extent it's overdone but the best way to
respond is not to say that it's overdone
but simply shed lights and that's the
way uh we consider that's that's the way
we want to do these tests let me also
say that the outcome is as important as
the process because in order to reach
this uh objective of uh of being uh of
of clarifying this this issue uh we have
to be exceedingly transparent in the
process and make sure as you said that
conflict of interest is dealt with at
each stage of the process so that's
that's the way that uh DCB views this
but I think the national supervisors as
well as I said I made reference before
to the very good uh relationship that
has been created between the two and it
is fundamental for to make progress on
this you also asked whether we are going
to stress government bonds uh we we are
sort of we we have to take decisions on
this it's not been discussed yet the
high level group hasn't really coped
with this issue
yet and uh but as I said we want to be
absolutely credible so the high level
Group which is B basically the exante
supervisory board uh will discuss this
when we will make a communication on the
asset quality review We foresee the
First Communication by mid October at
the latest where will be coped
with supervis
body on the supervisory body you see
it's not the ECB that appoints the
supervisory
board it's the member states so it's up
to them to appoint the supervisory board
but you can call the meetings and uh so
far you don't when we have when we have
but they haven't been appointed yet so
what meeting should I call if there are
no
members so most members are there and if
the meetings are not called there's no
Democratic control no no the Democratic
control is there we report all the times
about the high level group the high
level group is made up by most people
who will be part of the supervisory
board having said that it's up to the
member states to appoint the supervisory
board members it's not up to the
ECB so we we are in their hands here in
the meantime however we Mo we want to
move and move fast and move
well we don't want to be clogged
trapped by these very important
institutional steps so these
institutional steps will have to be
taken decisions have to be taken in the
mean time we will move forward thank you
we've overrun a bit but those were good
and interesting questions so the the the
we have to uh summon the Euro group if
they don't get on with the appointing uh
now for the GUI Nikos
chunes mad chairman my
question is on the role the ECB plays
within the troa
this is something that you did focus on
recently the Greek minister of the
economy stated that Greek
debt has reached a level of 180% of
GDP that
statement
clearly refutes the
responsibilities that um had been
mentioned the troa had mentioned a
figure of 160%
but above and beyond that the triker had
made a number of statements with
different
figures in other words the
trer of which the ECB is
part was
tling the the Greek uh recovery plan and
was trying to work out what was missing
from
it
so what are the third of the members of
the troa that's to say the ecb's
representatives um
doing well how do do they think about do
they think that Greek indebtedness is
sustainable do you have to bring the
debt level below 100% to be sustainable
and what are you actually discussing in
ECB are you discussing restructuring the
debt do you have a range of possible
scenarios well let me um me say that
basically this question asked whether
Greece needs a third
program and I think it's premature to
ask this because the second adjustment
program for Greece runs until the end of
2014 on the European side and the IMF
program will continue until early
2016 in our view it's too early to
already discuss now a possible followup
program or an extension of the current
one and uh also such decision will
depend for example also on the extent of
Greek market access at the end of next
year which is very hard to predict in
advance on uh on the role of the ECB in
the tro I think I've commented
before
we being uh being the uh responsible for
monetary
policy uh we in a sense it's good that
we are part of the tro at times of
Crisis we don't don't provide financing
under financial assistance
program and the ECB provides however
considerable liquidity support to banks
in Greece and in other
countries so we have incentive we have a
strong interest in being part of the
troa because this way we contribute with
our expertise to the design and the
monitoring of the programs but as I said
before this is linked to the period of
crisis
so I don't have much to add to what I
said thank
you oh yes
quickly I'm sorry may I return to my
first question you haven't replied to
that at all in other words what are the
relations between the
ECB and
the and the
other members of of the tro the IMF is
basically suggesting that Greek debt is
unsustainable and is making proposals
but what do you think about that what is
your position do you think it's a
sustainable level of debt if it's
reached a figure of 180% of GDP do you
think that's sustainable or
not frankly we see no reason the the
current assessment is that debt is
sustainable and we see absolutely no
reason to change it
I don't think you're going to get
anything further on that uh 180% debt
appears to be sustainable or whatever
the current debt is is sustainable they
may not be the same uh efd
s thank you madam president welcome
again to our
committee Mr drai I would like to
present a question about long-term
policy
is in the northern countries the
interest rate has been low in for for a
long time and you also mentioned that in
your introduction how important
accomodative policy is for a long time
to come or every time ECB makes
decisions on the key policy rates so
that they are low then markets are
rewarding it if there is some suspicion
even the slightest suspicion that the
rates are going to rise then the markets
become to be uh nervous I'm a little bit
worried myself whether the the
present interest rate has become a
normality a state that markets are
expecting to continue that it is normal
so I'm asking in what
conditions we can start raising the
rates again and is it to be is it
foreseeable even over the years and
therefore I'm also worried that the
present interest
rate um encourages leveraging and
indebting even though it politically we
want to avoid indebtedness as much as
possible thank
you thank
you the uh current forward guidance says
that interest rates will stay at the
present or lower level for an extended
period of
time this forward guidance is based on
our medium-term
inflation assessment inflation as I said
before has gone down in August for the
Euro area is going down in August from
1.6 in July to
1.3 and it is expected to remain on
below 2% on the low side of 2% for an
extended period of
time given the weakness of the economy
the high
unemployment so given that this is our
medium-term assessment our monetary
policy which has as a mandate the
maintaining of price stability and I
always say price stability in both
directions upward and
downward has issued this forward
guidance so we do expect the present or
lower levels of interest rate rates for
an extended period of time at the same
time inflation expectations remain
firmly
anchored so that's the in a sense the
that's the the scenario the economic
scenario that we will have to face for
as I said an extended period of
time now it's also true and I think I
think probably this is what is in the
back of your question it's also true
that low interest rates for long time
entail risks and we we know this and
we've seen this in the past so we are uh
very sensitive to risks that could be
there for financial stability stemming
from a very low level of interest rates
and if we were to see them we simply
would have to act through
macroprudential
instruments this is the framework so far
we see very very very limited evidence
that this is the case thank you
right uh I'm glad you mentioned macr
Prudential instruments I'm hoping we'll
come on to those uh did you wish
to come back no okay uh then for the EP
a happy looking Verna
Langan yeah here president Mr
President well the measures that the ECB
has taken so far are something I've
always
supported very emphatically since uh you
were the institution that performed best
in this crisis so I'd like to
contradict the colleagues that have once
again for the 10th or 12th time raised
the problem of the troa I think that's
absolutely
necessary however I don't agree with
everything that the ECB is doing and
therefore I'd like to pick up on what Mr
gigal
said and I'd like to say a few things
about the separation of money and
supervisory
policy you said uh that there would be
strict separation in money policy you're
uh
independent but uh otherwise there has
to be supervisory control either by
governments or by parliaments and I
don't think that's been fully discussed
how the supervision will be carried
out as long as there are problems in
certain
areas well
it was said that in December you decide
on a president and a vice president well
you should already begin with the
supervisory
Authority um and what's going to be the
link to member state level authorities
and then what about the Recovery Fund
that's supposed to be ready by January
2015 what do you say about Mr abu's
proposal to use the esm up to that point
and then uh to Anchor the fund in the
ECB don't you think that would be rather
dangerous because monetary and uh
supervisory Authority would be uh
together in the same institution and my
final question monetary
policy well the policy of the US fed and
the Japanese Central
Bank well
they're going for low interest rates and
quantita quantitative easing and now we
hear that low interest rates are a
threat to pension systems everything
that make up the social uh the social
welfare system in Europe are you going
to try to have uh International
discussions uh focused on going back to
an interest rate based system thank
you thank you
um it certainly would be optimal to have
this resolution fund be
established not in 10 years to be
completed not in 10 years time but with
a shorter
Horizon uh I would certainly agree with
you that uh the ECB should have nothing
to do with this
fund so I uh but I I don't know whether
this crossed any anybody's mind really
uh the ECB should not and will not have
anything to do with this
fund um it's also true that during the
period of time that the fund is
basically
underfunded there should be the
possibility of for the fund to borrow
money from some other
source and here a variety of
possibilities is
open and frankly I think the reflection
is still at its early early stage some
people have suggested the esm could
extend a credit line to the resolution
fund I am not sure that this is possible
within the existing
treaty uh but certainly the problem
exists and uh will have to be will have
to be
addressed on your second point about the
members and the supervisory
board I I can repeat what I said before
it's not up to the ECB to appoint the
members it's up to the member states so
when they will have appointed the
supervisory board members the
supervisory board can actually be
summoned and the meory boards can take
place on the low interest rates I I uh
certainly appreciate the concerns the
low interest rates create not only for
uh for finan Financial stability as I've
said before but for insurance life
insurance uh for
pensions and more generally for the
Savers all the Savers see them their
savings being penalized by low interest
rates for a long period of
time what what we do here is to have
monetary policy for the whole of the
Euro area so that is one one response
the second second thing I think I would
I would sort of um call on you to watch
the behavior of interest rates
especially in Germany in the last three
months four months they have gone up
even though our interest rates stay the
same and the reason is that um interest
rates on the government bonds in Germany
uh are low are have been for a long time
artificially low because Germany was the
safe heaven of capital flows from the
rest of the Euro area now with
confidence coming back flows are not as
strong as they were in the past and so
you see that other International
movements can actually have the desired
effect of raising interest rates on the
government bonds in
Germany now we we do have periodic
discussions with uh with other
colleagues in the rest of the world we
do have
discussions these discussions don't
reach the level of coordination however
so there is exchange of information
there is there are discussions
especially I would say as far as issues
linked to financial
stability thank you thank you uh now for
the EP uh Pablo zba
uh thank you madam
chair and welcome president
dragy I think that we
agree that we see some positive signs of
uh an economic recovery and uh to
congrat to Mr Ferrera on the case of of
Portugal I agree with you also when you
say that a banking Union would uh allow
us to accelerate that economic growth
but we have to ensure that this is
something which is valid for the medium
and
longterm uh in the short term of course
we still have the problem of credit and
the issue of
smmes I'm uh also wondering what the
same issue as Mr Langan low interest
rates I don't think that this is going
to have a real effect on uh the economy
of uh any country at all in my
country there is a real problem
withes
25% of uh
smes uh give access to credit as their
main problem that doesn't mean however
that the others don't have any problems
with getting access to credit at all and
credit is still more expensive for
Spanish smmes than smmes in other
countries we talked about the fact that
the
ECB has as one of its missions to inject
the liquidity into the market but I just
like to know if we provide that
liquidity how can we ensure that this
additional liquidity will really help
the real
economy and uh will not
simply be used to buy up public debt so
how can we
ensure that if liquidity additional
liquidity is actually provided that that
additional liquid liquidity will get to
the real economy and not end up
elsewhere let me first agree with you
that thees are the backbone of our
economies especially I would say in
those countries that have been affected
by the
crisis and I would also agree with you
that during this crisis financing
obstacles have increased for the
smmes in part these obstacles were
driven by the deterioration of their
financial situation shouldn't forget
that many smmes are highly leveraged
meaning that their existing debt is
pretty
high but certainly uh there are there
have been other factors and one of them
is the risk aversion by Banks the
so-called um rate of return on Landing
adjusted for risk in many of the stress
countries is is just not high enough for
banks to be persuaded to lend to
smmes and as you said some of them buy
government bonds instead of financing
the real economy but the other reason
which we still think is predominant so
we have basically weakness of the
balance sheets of the smmes we have risk
aversion by the Banks but the other
reason is really lack of
demand there uh has been uh there has
been a survey of smes credit flows we do
we do two types of surveys one is the
bank Landing survey which asks basically
asks the banks why they don't land and
then we also do more less frequently a a
survey on the other side namely asking
the smmes why don't they
borrow and um what the first reason they
quoted for not borrowing was basically
lack of
clients and the second reason was lack
of uh Banks U credit Supply so the the
main the most important reason that we
see now as depressing the still depress
in the credit flows is basically lack of
demand however we've taken we've taken
many measures really um we if you
compare often people compare our
programs with the funding for lending
program in the
UK we see that the
components namely a wide array of
counterparties uh
lower I would say
lower wider variety of
collateral and long maturity these are
the three components of the funding for
landing and these are also the three
components of our LTR we've been having
this in place since 20
well the end of
2011 so we've taken several measures
more recently we've taken we've decided
a lowering of rating requirements for
some asset back Securities including
those assets backed byme
loans we've decided the setting up of
additional credit claims so that Banks
can actually take the credits they make
to their clients as a collateral when
they come to the ECB for borrowing
money and also very recently in July
2000 this year uh we when we discussed
and we do these discussions periodically
we have these discussions periodically
we discussed the permanent collateral
framework we decided to introduce
measures that could support financing
like a reduction of EBS aircuts besides
a reduction of EBS s rating requirements
finally we are still working with eiib
and with the commission for structuring
and revamping the ABS market so as to
support further support the smmes in
this the ECB has for the time being a
purely advisory
role thank you thank you our questions
are getting a bit too long um now for
the snd Annie podim
thank you madam
chair
president I'd like to take a moment on
the low interest
rates I have other concerns to Mr
langers our colleague mentioned the
position in
Spain where is Mr
Langan
in a number of
countries there's a huge problem with
the lack of
liquidity with there being huge gaps in
the interest rates being paid for loans
from one Euro Zone member state to
another while in Germany you might be
able to borrow 2% in my country and and
others you uh would be borrowing at 45%
and others it's as much as 7 or 8%
that's perfectly true
now allow me to put it to you Mr dragi
that for a year
now three of The largest Greek
firms SES were were referred to a little
while ago but anyway three major Greek
firms have switched the
headquarters abroad in order to seek
funding
and M kka the largest F in the country
last week switched its headquarters to
Belgium so that it would have access to
the financial markets
now given that this is a problem linked
up to your
point that's to say the transposition of
monetary
policy this isn't something specific to
to Greece or Spain could I ask you what
you have in mind to avoid a two-speed
Euro Zone emerging when it comes to that
transposition of monetary
policy
well let me try to to give a a picture
of how fragmentation looks like
today we at the beginning of the crisis
we had uh we we have to look at
fragmentation on both sides funding and
landing at the beginning of the crisis
we had both we had the banks uh placed
in stress count countries that had
funding costs way higher than Banks
placed in core countries and we had
liquidity flows which were way lower in
the stress countries than in other
countries that is by and large
overcome what we have seen uh over the
last I would say six months
we've seen that deposits with the return
of confidence deposits domestic deposits
went back to their domestic
Banks what we do uh what we do there is
we look at how deposits grow in each
country and uh we compute a dispersion
coefficient and we've seen that this uh
dispersion between the growth rates of
deposits in different parts of the Euro
area is now at the same level as it was
in
2007 so this the bottom line of this is
that funding through deposits
fragmentation is by and large
gone now other forms of funding when
banks have to access Wholesales Market
issuing bonds that is not completely
gone but certainly we've notice the
shrinking of the funding
spreads on the lending side the progress
is admittedly much much slower and even
though again we see a decrease of
dispersion between Landing rates in
different parts of the Euro area we see
the conditions are still different and I
think there are also good reasons for
that if you consider the risk premium of
lending in a stress country to a firm
placed in a stress country Vis A the
risk premium for landing in to a firm
placed in a nonstress country you have a
big difference by itself second
government bonds yield different rates
so I think someone of the previous
speakers was actually hinting at that
Banks often rather than lending to the
economy they simply buy government bonds
they have much less risk and then they
have a return which is okay for their
profitability so there are issues like
that but again the key key reason is
demand we see we see that gradually our
accommodative monetary policy feds into
through the economy and gradually the
system is recovering as the recovery
will proceed we will see fragmentation
on the landing side as well going down
and shrinking it will become less risky
to land to
companies thank you of course if
Government bonds weren't zero risk we'd
have a happy little rebalancing of the
money going back to the economy instead
of being in government bonds perhaps um
now we'll go to uh the EP and asri
lilling thank you president Madame
chairman your
colleagues on the board uh which who
include my compatriot Mr M and and I'm
very pleased to see that he's putting
his experience to use and to the service
of the ECB after the problems he've had
Mr msh has just made some very
interesting statements to the Press
concerning the implementation of uh
single the single banking uh supervisory
mechanism the supervision that will
cover the 130 banks will soon be
operational that's what you've confirmed
but there's a problem a very important
one that remains to be dealt with that's
the issue of the back stop as it's
called what's necessary is to
determine
how the re capitalization that's
necessary will be spread among the
various governments
if there are uh serious gaps in the
balance sheet of a bank were to
appear I'd like to explain to
you that
uh what's at stake here is very
important let me explain this in detail
the resolution fund which is currently
on the
agenda is something uh where I need an
explanation how does what's the
connection between the back stop issue
on the one hand and resolution on the
other are they
complimentary are they the same thing or
are they
two fundamentally different
things I haven't really understood that
another question in a very interesting
book that's just been
published fris longle a journalist and
Economist
explains that uh
globalization is
uh suffering a downward
Trend uh there are significant
regressions particularly in the Euro
Zone and that's been seen since uh 2007
now globalization is on the way out if
this were to to prove true true what
about flows of international Capital
into the Euro Zone would that be a
problem in itself in particular for the
management of The single currency thank
you thank you I will answer first second
question we frankly we don't see
globalization going down and and if we
watch what's happened uh in with the
capital flows uh beginning since the
beginning of the year uh we see that
actually it's uh it's just the other way
around Capital flows continue to travel
freely in different parts of the world
creating different monetary
conditions um generally change in
interest rates and exchange rates uh
since the look at what happened since
the FED is uh communicating the
possibility of tapering or not tapering
you had flows first before you had
massive flows to emerging markets and
also significant flows into Euro area
then when the tapering possibility
emerged you had massive outflows from
Emerging Markets though the Euro area
was not really
affected so Capital flows are still uh
very very mobile and globalization is
not going
down
the first question is about the
SRM let me say that the ECB was formally
consulted on the SRM proposal earlier
this
month and an official ECB opinion will
be
published now let me reiterate the SRM
is a necessary complement to the
SSM it's important that the levels of
responsibility and decision making for
supervision and resolution are aligned
in order to achieve a well functioning
Financial Market
Union so the ECB welcomes the
commission's proposal for the SRM which
contains the three Essential Elements a
single system a single Authority and a
single
fund we also
strongly support the envisaged timeline
for the SRM on January 1st
2015 I've also had the opportunity to
comment that the two roles of assessment
the viability of a
bank and caring taking care of its
resolution should be separate the
ECB as a supervisor will do the
assessment but everything else would
have to be done by the s RM as far as
the um role of the ACB in the SRM the
view of the ECB is that its presence
should only be the one of an
observer finally on a legal basis I
understand from the legal services of
the ECB that article 114 of the treaty
is indeed an appropriate possible basis
for the proposed SRM
regulation I understand also that this
this
this this view is shared among the legal
service of all EU
institutions and um the legal service of
the council also has informed that
article
114 is
sufficient now on on the back
stop there are the same word is being
used for for different for different
meanings really the what what we refer
as a back stop in the context of the
SRM is the fact that this fund the fund
the single fund of the SRM will take 10
years to be
completed so the issue is what happens
if before the end of the 10 years we
have need of this fund and then the
possibility for this fund to borrow
money not money for free to borrow money
from another source or to be there that
is what is called the back stop for the
SRM the possibility of having for the
SRM a credit line where they can draw in
case there was there wasn't enough in
the fund
itself right thank you uh now for the
snd Emily
Turnin um thank you first of all a
comment um I I think what you what you
said about your relations to other uh
central banks was was interesting you
said basically that you have some
discussions but not really any
formalized decisionmaking structure and
I think it just just a comment I think
it points to a major flaw of our
cleaning up after the crisis that we
still have not put in place a Global
Financial architecture but but that's
that was just a comment so my question
is on your new role as supervisor one of
today's topics and something that I've
asked uh others before but that I still
have not had a good answer to so it's
about the asset quality review Mr Diel
Blum was here some weeks ago and he said
that the quality of the asset quality
review is very important and we of
course agree to that that's clear and
you have talked about credibility
today but uh he did not have any
concrete proposals on how to ensure this
not only the quality of the methods used
but also the independence of the uh
experts Ed so my question is how will
you ensure the high quality especially
in light of the criticism in after the
the last stress test carried out on
methods and secondly how will you ensure
Independence especially among the
private sector experts and how do you
define independence in this case how and
you you said about back stops that there
should be National back stops in place
and my question is are they in place is
it realistic for
Spain Greece maybe even
France the first let me say the
comprehensive assessment will be based
on a thorough and rigorous
methodology this methodology is
currently in preparation in the context
of the SSM
preparations this uh these preparations
as I said before will be supported by
the advice from experienced external
consultants and the ECB as I said before
has launched a
tender uh the and has hired an external
consultant second a carefully crafted
centrally centrally Leed that's key
project management function will be
established to ensure that this robust
methodology will be applied
consistently and independently across
all banks that fall within the scope of
the
exercise so it's important centrally LED
should be consistently and independently
applied to ensure that it doesn't become
fragmented and that the results are
fully comparable
this effort will be supported by
experienced external project
managers critical process management and
quality assurance will be interwoven
with every step of the methodology to
guard The credibility of the process and
of its
outcomes now on the back stops well I uh
we have to take into account first of
all that uh the um banks in the meantime
have raised considerably their level of
provisioning and uh so the the role for
the national back stops is there and
it's h it's
realistic also for the countries that
you
mentioned thank
you okay thank you um I think Emily I
thought that uh Minister diesel Bloom D
Bloom was quite categoric about the use
of Consultants throughout and also about
the bailing hierarchy I mean maybe one
could poke holes in some of his
responses but I thought that he was
quite strong on that point um now where
am I going um to the EP and marann
Tyson uh thank you thank
you thank you
m
thank you and thank you um president
dragi for being here from the ECB today
I would like to express the following
reservations and ask some questions
President we have come a long way with
all of the institutions together we've
produced a lot of legislation taken a
lot of political decisions a lot of
standard and non standard measures have
been taken and I think that we have uh
gone a long way towards ensuring that
future such crisis can be avoided and
that we are uh getting the Train on the
right track to prevent such crisis again
in the future and to uh create more
confidence but we haven't completely
finish that work we have the SRM that
hasn't been completed yet and my
question is when you start your asset
quality review and other quality tests
of the bank there's always the risk and
I think we have to bear that in mind
that uh problems May crop up here and
there and that raises the question in my
mind of how we are going to
ensure that uh the first piece of
negative news that comes out will not
trigger a panic reaction and once again
lead to chaos how can we avoid that is
that something that you aware of that
the lack of confidence that we have at
uh the moment means that we don't have
sufficient resilience in the economy and
in the financial markets so who's going
to step in here is there something that
is being discussed between the
institutions I put this question to
commissioner barer and he told me that
he had raised it with the finance
ministers at the last efin Council that
we have to have communication about this
issue and that people need to be aware
of this and they shouldn't be surprised
if some negative news does emerge but is
the ECB preparing for this uh can
communication make us more resilient and
who is going to take this responsibility
or are my concerns
unfounded no no your concerns are really
well founded they're not unfounded at
all we we do share them and uh we are
aware that we have to cope with them and
be prepared uh the past experience is
also quite instructive now things may be
slightly better now this time both
because banks have uh significantly
increased
provisioning uh they have raise
significant amount of capital so the
overall situation and generally speaking
there's much more confidence around than
at the time the previous stress tests
have been
made the but our
assessment will be comprehensive and
stringent and uh because we need a clear
overview of all the significant entities
for which we are going to uh to perform
the task of the
supervisor it's too early to to to to
say what figure can come
out so we we do believe that this
assessment will uh increase in
transparency will actually increase
confidence provided we are ready to cope
with the shortfalls that's why I've been
insisting on the importance of National
back stops since the very beginning they
are absolutely essential to ensure The
credibility of the asset quality review
and the stress tests if there are no
National back stops the world will say
ah these figures have come out the way
they are because of the fear of coming
out with worse figures in absence of
national back stops that's why they are
absolutely essential to give credibility
for to the
exercise and um so that's what uh that's
what we are we are trying to do to be as
transparent as possible stringent
consistent across the board independent
application but be ready to
intervene thank
you um thank you now for LD it's ramal
trosa thank you very much Madam chair uh
Mr dragi good afternoon
two questions the first one concerning
uh banking
Union the ECB is going to supervise some
European Banks and for me as a Catan MP
this is a good new that all Spanish
banks will be under European
supervision but a question is who should
pay for the mistakes in supervision of
the
ECB the second question concerning the
ACB
supervision I believe that there is no
super Vision credibility without
failur credibility requires that some
banks
fail the ECB should have the red button
to force the failure of a bank because
now we see that in some member states
there are banks that are declared too
big to fail and this means huge losses
for taxpayers and social cats and in
other member states that there are U
quite large Banks for instance Germany
the West Land is bankin that are forced
to fail so who should have the red
button to force the failure of a bank
thank
you thank
you well I on the first question I
really don't want to I want even to
think about on who should pay if the ECB
makes a mistake but uh the the the the
SEC the second point is actually very
important we we um we said since the
very beginning that the moment to assess
the viability of a certain financial
institution and how to take care about
that institution are two different
moments different tasks and should be
performed by different
institutions so the ECB will
tell the SRM
that a certain institution may not be
viable then it's up to the SRM very much
like it is with the FDIC in the United
States to
decide what to do with this institution
it can be sold it can be recapitalized
it can be merged it can be
dissolved so there are many different
ways but but since all these different
possibilities
May uh may have an influence
on on the national budgets on the
taxpayers money it should be completely
different the task from the supervisor's
task that's the uh that's the and that's
by the way that's how it works in
different countries
nowadays you have the supervisor who
basically tells the budget Authority the
finance ministry or the
treasury that a certain institution is
not viable and ought to be either
resolved or taken care namely sold or
merged with others and the two tasks are
kept separate as far as I know in all
member
countries thank
you could you want to come back Ral if
if if I may these are some of the issues
that we are discussing as well in the
trialogue on the resolution and Recovery
directive in terms of how how much
flexibility uh there should be for uh
different banks to be resolved in
different way and the Parliament wants a
a presumptive path for investors uh and
uh rather less um different outcomes so
but that's something that is still under
negotiation um Mario I I've got a
question for you um about uh macr
Prudential um uh policy policy and the
EC ECB I obviously macroed policy which
you you know is is an important new tool
can be exercised uh by the ECB when it
takes over as the um uh the competent
Authority in in the SSM but there's also
a side to macroprudential policy that
would impact on the monetary policy side
in terms of trying to cope with the fact
that one interest rate for all member
states uh doesn't work and therefore
pressing on the banks and the bank
lending and such like is another way of
doing it h who who's going to be doing
this and how is the if you like the macr
prenti policy uh going to be dealt with
when it does Bridge across if you like
the sort of supervisory side and the
monetary policy side um and you you
haven't got a sort of middle body uh
that would be calling the shots whereas
in the Bank of England they've got a
kind of middle Bott body looking both
ways that does it how how will you cope
with that within the
ECB well we're actually working on this
the macroprudential policy it's going to
be um basically it's going to be falling
both within the supervisory board tasks
and the governing Council tasks and
we've
uh we have I mean we we are in the
process actually of finalizing in ways
of uh
cooperating with special
meetings uh on this point with an
interchange of
information uh so we are in the process
now exactly of uh finding the right
arrangement for this also keep in mind
that in the ECB we have the financial
stability part that will also deal with
this uh so uh it's it's something it's a
concern that is well present in in our
minds and we have to uh be ready to
provide uh provide the um with uh
provide you provide the Euro area with a
reasonable way of handling
this it's um it's an area that is
admittedly gray where you can but the
however in our case it's in a sense the
task of keeping separate monitor policy
for macroed dential policy is made
easier by our treaty you know that our
primary mandate is to keep price
stability in the medium term so that is
makes our task easier because we know
that uh no matter what the primary
mandate is the first and foremost
mandate that we have to comply
with having said that you may have local
problems we we view macroprudential po
policy in a in a in an area as complex
as the Euro area is as a way to cope
with local
problems uh localized bubbles in
different for example in different parts
of the Euro area but that doesn't have
an impact directly on monetary
policy and would that be then ECB proper
doing that though or would it be the ECB
through the supervisory we we are
discussing we are discussing exactly who
does what in these days
exactly okay sorry to put my finger on a
difficult Point um uh we we've got a
little bit of time and I know Mr bokros
has been waving at me uh uh he hasn't
he's not on the list for a question but
you have a question yeah
okay thank you madam chair in July
2012 uh Mr President you made a historic
statement saying that the ECB we will
make whatever it takes to save the
Euro uh we can call it Forward guidance
because it had a major tremendous
positive impact uh but not on monetary
policy on fiscal policy rather it saved
many sovereigns from going
bankrupt while at the same time as uh it
was discussed already uh the monetary
transmission mechanism is not perfect
effect really because there is very
little credit growth and very little
real growth in the economy is it not an
irony of history that uh uh these kind
of forward guidance statements um are
much more effective as a backstop to
fiscal policy rather than helping the
real economy in terms of monetary policy
thank
you I would agree with you that the omt
has been extremely effective I wouldn't
agree with you that it's been effective
as a fiscal back stop at all omt is an
instrument of monetary policy we should
remember that um at the time the uh the
risks that we were addressing through
omt were the risks of redenomination
which was a
euphemism for
indicating highly disruptive scenarios
for the Existence itself of the euro
and um some of the uh interest rates
that we were seeing prevailing in the
Euro area were not justified by
fundamentals but simply by this
self-fulfilling
expectation of a
dissolution of the Euro and that's what
the omt addressed at that time and this
was a monetary policy
objective because such disruptive scenar
scenarios where impairing are achieving
of our primary mandate namely price
stability in the medium term so that was
the objective having said that you know
the conditions for actually activating
omt and these are stringent conditions
on the macroeconomic program with the
possibility of a primary market purchase
by the country that is asking for it so
there was no I would say no intention at
all to address the fiscal problems of
different
countries the underlying conviction uh
is and was that um if a country has an
unsustainable fiscal position there is
nothing one can do to make it
sustainable other than the country
itself and um sustainability ought to be
valued at interest rates that that
reflect the underlying
fundamentals I think that was the at the
root of the
omt uh
design thank
you okay I'll take one more question now
from Philip Lamberts and then we can
have a short break which uh Mario has
asked for before the next part of the
hearing which will be on the European
systemic risk board Philip I took from
uh Sharon look at that it should be
short so it will uh Mr President you
mentioned uh that lending to the real
economy uh did not match the uh return
the rate of return expectation of the
financial industry wouldn't you agree
with the fact that the financial
industry has been addicted to rates of
returns that are incompatible with a
stable
economy yes indeed yes indeed and and
part and uh just to follow up on this
point you see part of what we are seeing
today is that all the all the all the
regulation that we've been putting into
place since the end of the since the
financial crisis and we are continue to
doing so is meant to make the banking
system and generally the financial
system less risky than it was
before so one would think that yes the
rates of return are lower
today than they were before because we
knew as you said they were addicted to a
rate of return which was not sustainable
through time however being a rate of
return lower you also have lower risk
nowadays but it's taking time it's
taking time for the markets for the
financial industry to appreciate this
fact that rates of turn are going to be
and stay
lower at the same time risk is also
lower so it's a different combination of
risk return that people should start
appreciating and I think of course the
situation today is uh is uh way better
than it was three years ago as you've
seen Banks now can again raise capital
on the markets the overall situation has
improved proved from a confidence
Viewpoint so gradually it seems that the
shareholders are understanding this new
configuration of lower rate of return
and lower risk and they are responding
consequently but here it comes um the
what I was saying before about the asset
quality review comes into play and it's
very very important
because uh one in order to convince the
private sector to invest in the banking
industry one not only needs lower uh
risk but also one needs transparency on
the bank's balance sheets that's why the
asset quality review may turn out to be
very important in reactivating the
credit flows of the banking sector to
the real
economy thank
you right thank you very much so thank
you that brings us to the end of the U
sort of monetary policy side of things
as requested we'll take a a short break
now for about uh five minutes and then
we can uh start the the next session uh
probably a few minutes early but then
that allows Mario to get away to get a
plane so uh back in five minutes please
thank
against
e
for
yeah
e
for
spe
right welcome back colleagues we are now
going on to the uh hearing uh uh still
with the president of the ECB but this
time in his
role
as uh this time in his role as chairman
of the European systemic risk board so
again uh we'll have a few comments uh uh
from Mario uh in in that capacity and
then on to the ESRB uh question and
answer session
Mario thank you thank you Madame chair
honorable members it is a pleasure for
me to appear before this committee today
in order to inform you about the
activities of the European systemic risk
board first let me say that uh in the
course of last meeting Governor Carney
Bank of England was named first vice
chair of the
SRB since uh we last met there have been
signs of a gradual turnaround in
Europe's economic
Outlook while these developments are
encouraging and uh still as I had the
chance to say many times in their
infancy risk to financial stability of
course remain in my remarks today I will
report on the work the ESRB is
undertaking to address some of these RIS
risks in the fields of insurance Banking
and Market
infrastructures I will also report on
two other areas of ongoing work the
assessment of the implementation of the
ESRB first
recommendation and its guidance on the
use of macroprudential instruments to
assist National
authorities the insurance sector plays
an important role both both in the
financial system and in the economy at
large apart from assuming risk that
households or firms do not want to Bear
themselves it also acts as an
investor at the same time there is a
need to deal with possible risks and
vulnerabilities that stem from insurance
some of which have the potential to
affect the stability of the Financial
system life insurance companies
especially those that promise guarantees
guaranteed
returns are suffering on account of the
current
environment of low interest
rates looking at this from a micr
Prudential point of view aopa has
correctly advised firms to modify their
business models
this is crucial for addressing the issue
at its economic
Source if business models are not
modified insurance companies could
search for higher yields by investing in
riskier
assets but this would expose them to
potential losses through increases in
Risk
premum firms have limited incentives to
address these vulnerabilities is if
regulatory regimes do not bring them to
light a failure to do so would weaken
the sector's ability to fulfill the
important role it has to play in the
economy spillovers to The Wider
Financial system through direct linkages
and common exposures cannot be ruled
out awareness that the insurance sector
may be of systemic relevance
has grown at the international level the
financial stability board has recently
announced a list of systemically
important Global
insurers five out of nine are
European the International Association
of Insurance
supervisors has developed a framework
for policy responses including effective
resolution and a higher loss absorption
capacity in the United States
systemically important financial
institutions including insurance
companies will become subject to
Consolidated supervision by the Board of
Governors of the Federal Reserve System
and to enhanc credential
standards in Europe work to finalize the
new system of credential regulation
solvency to is continuing in this
respect the European Parliament is
playing an essential role in its
capacity as
co-legislator solvency 2 reflects the
risk profile of insurers better than
solvency one and it enhances their risk
management
capacity at the same time the new system
should deal with possible unintended
consequences of excessive shortterm
Market volatility
including procyclical effects as the
currently debated long-term guarantee
package aims to
do as requested by the European
Parliament the ESRB has participated in
the economic assessment of that package
undertaken by yopa and supports the main
conclusions
reached given the issues I have just
emphasized it is crucial that this
package ensures both adequate Capital
levels at all times and full
transparency of their
application all risks should be
addressed
appropriately the banking system plays a
crucial role in the financing of the
economy at the same time its role in the
unfolding of the financial crisis has
highlighted a number of
vulnerabilities in important steps are
being taken to address these
vulnerabilities and to deliver the
healthier banking system that European
citizens
deserve this too is an area in which
this Parliament has played a major role
approving the regulation on the single
supervisory
mechanism the forthcoming comprehensive
Bank assessment conducted by the
ECB conducted in a way consistent with
EBA
recommendations announced in March this
year has the potential to strengthen the
confidence on the soundness of the banks
within the single supervisory
mechanism that in turn would reduce
Banks funding costs and lower the cost
of credit for firms and
households this requires clear
communication as well as has credible
and effective exante mechanisms
including fiscal back stops wherever
needed for absorbing any Capital
shortfalls that such a review might
reveal at the ESRB we are looking at two
structural features of the European
banking system that the financial crisis
has
highlighted first the large size of the
banking system relative to the real
economy and second the concentration of
losses in certain Landing
segments in many countries the rapid
growth of Bank assets with the support
of increased leverage proved to be
unsustainable once credit losses
materialized some sovereigns that had to
support their banking system came under
pressure and the leveraging constrained
the extension of credit to to the real
economy this Amplified the crisis during
the downturn and continues to weigh on
the
recovery against this background the
esb's general board is continuing to
reflect on how the size of the banking
sector relative to the economy affects
the supply of socially beneficially
Financial
Services The Advisory scientific
committee has likewise started to work
on this
issue during the crisis Banks losses
were often concentrated in certain
Landing
segments in a number of countries losses
on property loans have required large
scale public sector intervention in the
banking
system but even Niche segments such as
shipping Finance have required
intervention in individual banks in some
countries cyclical sectors to which
banks have high exposures in the
European Union include construction and
property consumer durables mainly the
automobile industry and materials and
Fabrication mainly steel and
chemicals the SRB is conducting further
work in this
field I'll now turn to the role of
central counterparties
ccps which form a crucial part of the EU
Financial
system as you know the G20 countries
have agreed that all standardized
overthe counter derivaties should be
cleared through such
counterparties while ccps offer a number
of Economic and risk reducing benefits
they're also becoming systematically
relevant nodes in the financial
system this entails a number of
macroprudential
risks the procyclicality of ccp's margin
rules and practices is a key
concern increasing margin requirements
in times of stress and decreasing them
in Good Times May make sense from the
perspective of an individual
CCP but also carries the risk of
increasing the cyclical sensitivity of
the financial
system these vulnerabilities May grow
with the importance of
ccps while esma has already Incorporated
some helpful Provisions into its
technical standards their effectiveness
from a macroprudential
perspective might be enhanced through
additional mitigating measures of a
counter cyclical
nature ccps also need robust recovery
plans and resolution regimes in order to
avoid a disorderly
insolvency finally there is also the
risk of contagion particularly across
ccps that clear the same products under
the so-called interoperability
Arrangements evolving CCP markets need
to be designed in such a manner that
limits the spillovers of potential
distress at one CCP to
another to this end specific guidelines
have been already issued by esma
nevertheless given the systemic
importance of ccps it is important that
there broad set of tools available to
increase their resilience to
Contagion EU legislation has provided
the ESRB
with a clear role in these areas for
example under the provisions of the
European market infrastructure
regulation Emir the SRB has been asked
to examine the potentially exacerbating
impact that the procyclicality of margin
practices at ccps may have and to
monitor the design of interoperability
Arrangements the ESRB considered these
issues at its latest General board
meeting and has commissioned further
work let me also update you on two items
of ongoing work first the assessment of
the implementation of the esb's first
recommendation as you know ESRB
recommendations are soft tools
accompanied by an act or explain
mechanism
thus from an accountability perspective
it is important to assess the actions of
member States including possible
explanations for their reaction after an
ESRB recommendation has been
issued for its first recommendation on
Landing in foreign currency the ESRB has
just completed the full the First full
cycle from the issuance of of a
recommendation to the assessment of its
implementation as you may remember the
recommendation sets out a series of
measures to tackle possible systemic
risks of lending in foreign currency to
the non- financial private
sector the srbs general board is in the
process of finalizing its assessment
which will be published in the next few
weeks and looks forward to applying a
similar procedure to the next
assessments of the SRB
recommendations the second item relates
to the guidance on the use of
macroprudential instruments provided for
in the recently approved European
Capital
rules as you know the new European
Capital rules will start entering into
force in
2014 they provide for a range of
macroprudential instruments that
National authorities will be able to
deploy as I mentioned to you at my
previous hearing on July the 8th the
ESRB is working with member states on
guidance on how National authorities can
use these instruments in a coordinated
manner I'll provide you with more
details on this matter at the next
hearing thank you very much for your
attention I'm now available for
questions thank you very much um uh
thank you for telling us about the
appointment of the new first vice chair
we are all already investigating when we
can have a hearing with the vice chairs
is likely uh to be early next year due
to the workload of this Committee in
committee and also Diaries of other
people but we will be doing that as
before um as you've mentioned insurance
and quite a lot of us are working quite
hard to try and get solvency 2 finished
within the framework of the of the
omnibus 2 uh proposals I I won't tax on
the details of that but in the systemic
context are insurance companies becoming
more systemic because they are now
threatened with bailin under Bank
resolution and Recovery uh whereas
previously there would have been the
implicit uh guarantee to the banks so
does that move them up the systemic risk
agenda well
the the concept of being systemic is
different in banking and insurance for
banking the bean systemic is linked to
the possibility of Bank runs and
possible transformation of liquidity
problems into solvency problems for
insurance being systemic is linked to
the possibility that a certain economic
function like Risk diversification would
disappear for example no re insurance
anymore moreover vulnerabilities in the
insurance sector would translate
themselves into a lack of long-term
investment in the economy or in the
worst case in procyclical fire
sales based on this work is ongoing at
International levels both in the FSB and
in the
IIs to set up a macroprudential view of
insurance
vulnerabilities major systemic players
have been recently identified as I was
saying before by the FSB
IIs and as saying five out of nine are
European
conclusions uh in conclusion I think
insurance is
systemic uh but differently from Banks
and not necessarily because of the
potential baings that you you were
referring but silly that is also a
dimension that we have to consider okay
thank you if I can press you on a
slightly related but different point you
mentioned long-term investment and there
are now various proposals around to try
and get insurance and pensions firms
more interested in uh long-term
investment but they are demanding that
there be some kind of guarantee whether
it be from the eiib or or or elsewhere
so if if we end up putting in uh
essentially governmental guarantees onto
long-term investment that's in insurance
compan companies have we not just
transferred what was a subsidy to Banks
to do long-term investment and other
things uh into a subsidy for insurance
companies or an
underwriting the the the this function
of being a long-term investor for the
insurance companies has been a
longstanding one and so and that's in a
sense the good side to this that they
provide an anti anti cyclical role so
they are the typical institutional
investors which are crucial for finance
and infrastructure Investments which are
typically
longterm and they do play a role against
the short termism in the
economy so even without guarantees I
should say that recently there has been
a tendency of large insurers to enter
into more medium and short-term Landing
in originating
loans so this might help as to aging
risk of Global Credit Crunch at the time
when banks have problems Landing but it
should be supported by adequate risk
management and capacity to price
risk so I I'm not sure that the
insurance sector does need supplementary
guarantees to undertake the same type of
investment it's always been taken in the
past okay okay so they're asking they
may not get then um and now we'll move
on to the uh EP uh and uh question
BYO welcome Mr
dragy may I tell you that I welcome what
you said in your presentation
particularly regarding the importance of
the banking system
for the economies of EU member
states one of the elements that's very
relevant here is the level of confidence
Savers can have in the system if we're
already working well within the banking
Union on the
SSM we still have work to do on
resolution and and deposit
guarantees when our citizens and firms
realized that the principle of the Balin
was
there regarding the uh 100,000 EUR
savings um limits new position under the
the hierarchy I I had to reassure them
so could I ask you Mr try whether you
have any solutions which at the right
time will provide confidence for
European
Savers well the
uh at the general level
the
best the best support of European saving
is the return of confidence in the
economy
and the establishment of a of a firm
recovery within the specific context of
resolution we have to distinguish
between going concerns and gone
concerns for the gone concerns we have a
welldefined
pecking
order where we have said several times
that there should be depositor
preference on one hand and bailing not
the equity on the other
hand in
between we will have different
categories of creditors and then we have
the going
concerns
where we ought to be extremely careful
in thinking about bail in when the bank
is still
viable the best answer to this uh
situation is to
have a certain set of instruments by the
going concerns issued by the going
concerns that would be called in in case
certain conditions were to
materialize that's why the role of
Supervisors is also important from this
Viewpoint thank
you did you want to come back
thank you I'd like take this opportunity
to ask you for a comment regarding a
situation I discovered recently I'm
Portuguese and Portuguese nonfinancial
firm in December
2012 had to pay on average
6.2% to get a loan whereas in other EU
member states firms are paying
interest rates which are only a third of
that what do you think can be done to
overcome that
situation the um this situation is the
product of a financial crisis that has
created fragmentation in the Euro
area and
um though on uh on the funding cost side
we've seen significant improvements for
the
banks we've seen a more limited
Improvement on the landing
side and uh we still see that U Landing
costs differ across different
countries this partly has to do however
with the fact that uh we have to accept
that the risks of lending in the
stressed economies is higher than it is
in the non-stressed economy
second that many banks in the stressed
economies do buy significant amount of
their government debt and the interest
rates on the government debt are
significantly higher than the interest
rates on the government debt issued by
the nonstress
countries the this in a sense offers
the what sort of tells what sort of way
out will be out of this clearly the
establishment of the recovery the
continuation of fiscal
consolidation will both increase
confidence reduce the risk premium
reduce the interest rates on government
bonds and therefore improve the funding
and the landing to the real
economy so does that mean then that
carry trade is what deprives smmes and
others of funding in the
economy it's one of the alternative
Investments if indeed if the interest
rates were lower the banks would lend
more or would lend the lower costs I'm
not sure whether they would lend more
because you have to look at what is the
actual risk aversion by the banks in the
economy what are the actual risks what
is more specific spefically the rate of
return adjusted for
risks but certainly if the economy
were were U more uh if the recovery were
more established you would see that
these risk premum would go down if the
fiscal consolidation progress was more
established you would see that interest
rates on govern bonds would be
lower thank and and if the risk weight
on the sovereign debt was higher
including if banks actually had it
properly higher in their own internal
models where they're supposed to that
would improve lending to the real
economy that's that's a quite that's a
quite difficult uh quite difficult
question on one hand one would think
that making lending to governments more
expensive should make lending to firms
relative less
expensive on the other hand if you
increase the capital absorption for
landing to governments namely buying
government bonds you would have less
Capital available for landing to the
real economy so it's not an easy
question to answer what it would be the
net effect of of having risk weights on
top of this if you were to have risk
weights for Lending to the governments
you should also think that that these
risk rates would be higher for the
stressed countries than they would be
for the non-stress countries and
therefore the absorption of capital
would be higher for the stressed
countries than it would be for the
non-stressed countries so you can see
the the dimensions of this uh of the
answer to your question are are
complex it's a mess we've got ourselves
into that we're not getting ourselves
out of in that sense now for the snd uh
s El
C thank you and thank you thank you
chair and thank you Mr President for
your introduction I would like to say
something about uh Shadow
Banking and uh you know that the
commission last week approved a gradual
plan uh concerning money market funds
and you know that money market funds
play a an important role in the short
term for financing of um banking in
governments but they can also represent
a systemic risk the liquidity and
stability of these funds must be
guaranteed if the
uh risk system is going to cover them
then um external ratings are also being
addressed uh support from sponsors
there's often a reference to the greater
risk of runs on funds
uh when it comes to CFS which have a
more
variable uh
value there will be specific
requirements uh for cnfs of 3% do you
think that this is a good approach by
the commission or do you think that we
need to go further and
uh and as is indicated by the European
systemic risk board perhaps C enough
should be uh banned
uh in favor of VFS and are there other
aspects of money market
funds that uh should be looked at from
the standpoint of systemic risk and
address thank
you thank you thank you the let me say
the ISB ISU a recommen a public
recommendation on December 20th 2012 to
the European Commission on money market
fund
we follow the line of thinking which is
shared by the Central Banking
Community see for example positions of
the Federal Reserve in us where the role
of money funds is in terms of size and
economic functioning more important than
in US according to this line of thinking
money market funds with a constant net
asset value the so-called
cnaps represent an economically
equivalent alternative to deposit
services offered by credit
institutions for these reasons CA should
either be submitted to the same
regulatory Provisions as Banks or
legislation should provide for their
compulsory conversion into variable net
asset values
vavs cves represent a systemic risk
because an investor run is
possible without without however the
possibility for Regulators to intervene
with the same instruments as with the
banks the European commission has
proposed on September 4th a proposal for
a regulation of the European Parliament
and of the Council of money market
funds proposal of the commission
proposes a different solution CS are not
prohibited per se but require but
requested to set up a 3% cash buffer on
the asset side These funds which are not
able to respect this regulatory
requirement would be
compulsorily converted into
vavs the ESRB will assess the recent the
recent proposal of the European
commission also in view of its part
recommendation and I think we will do
this in the course of
2014 so the answer to your specific
question about whether 3% is enough or
not will be given later
on at this point we I think I did say
enough to let you know what is our
thinking about
this thank you all right we might need
it a bit quicker than that but apart
from that um uh because I think we'll be
looking at it before next year um now
for Aldi ol
Schmidt thank you Madame chair let me
start uh Mr President
to to salute you for your new gender
policy within your bank one one could
say that you listen to this house uh the
council did
not
uh what are the consequences Mr
President of the creation of the fully
fledged banking Union SSM
SRM for the ESRB
uh could this institutional model or
framework risk to be
complex and and make rapid actions more
difficult and I would like to also ask
you because I'm coming from a country
outside the Euro Zone and I regret it
but that's the case what will be the
case for banks outside the Euro Zone
with branches in the Euro Zone I've
asked a question to someone else I don't
need to mention the name and I really
don't understand what will happen if
they could be uh systemically risky
lastly you cannot leave this house Mr
President without saying anything about
the election yesterday this is a this is
a political body and and our mission is
political do if I'm looking at the
market right now it's it's a bit
jumpy will this election in Germany
create more financial stability within
Europe thank
you thank you I appeal to Madam chair to
be Exempted from answering this
question and I hope that my appeal is
accepted on on the first point is
basically how how will the ESRB and the
SSM coexist
and um our view is that they can operate
in a contiguous but different
institutional area the SRB is a
network the SSM will be a fully-fledged
institution the SRB has only soft Powers
the SSM will take binding
decisions the SRB collects all central
banks and supervisory authorities the
SSM only the Euro area
the SSM will exercise some of the powers
which today are in the hands of the SRB
members crucial powers in the area of
banking
supervision and share competences with
national macroprudential authorities in
the areas of in the area of
banking the tasks assigned to the SRB by
the crd4 and
crr will continue to be exercised by the
SRB
an important overlap in terms of
membership exists between the ECB
governing Council and the ESRB General
board ensuring that the necessary flow
of information on crucial
macroprudential issues will actually
flow across and we got to make sure that
this
works The Advisory scientific committee
has recently published a report on this
issue which I would invite you to look
at as a an interesting background
documentation then you asked me about
the banks that are not residing in the
Euro area but have branches in the Euro
area in these cases the supervision will
be carried out according to the normal
practices today where you have councils
of Supervisors domestic and the home and
the host country supervisors they will
nothing is expected to change from that
viewpoint with respect to what it is
today the difference being that before
you had National supervisors on our side
and tomorrow you'll be having the
central supervisor the SSM but other
than that nothing should should actually
change thank
you may I ask repeat my question you so
the the your answer is that you can see
no problems with this new framework for
acting very rapidly in in in in
problematic
times no no I see no no specific problem
if if if we are successful in
establishing an effective SSM I would
see no problem parts of the um I would
say parts of the success lies exactly in
what you said uh we should be able to
act with speed
Independence and lack of uh conflict of
interest from this Viewpoint the present
framework is certainly preferable from
the from the previous one as far as
speed is concerned however we'll have to
work on that to make sure that we are
equally fast in implementing decisions
that are taken by the center and
implemented at National
level buta that is not to assume that
the commission proposal at the moment is
perfect um uh we have yet to get our
hands on it um and we will uh now for
the greens Philip
Lamberts I'll speak English to make it
easy for everyone so uh you spoke about
insurance and about Banks so I'll ask
quick questions on each on insurance uh
in uh omnibus 2 in this uh sort of well
so-called volatility balancer it seems
that uh the the uh the dampening of the
volatility of the market is stronger is
actually only one way that is when it's
going downside but not when it's going
upside in other terms it can indeed do
something uh to avoid the effect of of
fire sales but it doesn't do anything to
prevent Bubbles and uh seen from a
systemic risk perspective I would expect
this to work both ways and not in a
single Direction second on banks your
colleague uh and Country mate Andrea
Henry
mentioned to the eoin in vus that we had
had a big progress in Europe that uh
Banks were now reaching a leverage ratio
in Europe of
3.75% which sounds quite weak actually
uh what do you make out of some
proposals that are being floated around
saying well a we've not been strict
enough in CD for on Leverage and that we
should basically Target a 10% uh
leverage ratio and and impose it at
least on systemic institutions uh would
that do wouldn't that go some way into
really uh forcing more stability and
more risk aversions from the banks
because well I've got my doubts on risk
related assets as you may
know on on the first on the first
question we got to make sure that any
measure that alleviates the impact of
short-term volatility first doesn't
create in incentives for under
capitalization of insurance corporations
or for concentration of risk second and
here comes more specifically to your
points measures should have to be
symmetric in nature not asymmetric this
means that buffers should be created
when economic conditions are
favorable third measures should be
transparent and this means that
investors should be regularly informed
about the economic impact of these
measures the balance sheet of the
companies and fourth vulnerabilities and
this goes without saying but it's always
worth repeating vulnerabilities should
not be
hidden on U on the second
Point um the we had we had several
numbers being floated on what is the
right leverage ratio we had the Basel
committee which uh had said
3% uh and then we had I think
5% also being mentioned as another
leverage
ratio uh when we look at leverage ratios
we also look at International
comparisons and um and one point that's
often made is that leverage ratios are
lower for US Banks than they are for
European
Banks now I we got to be cautious here
here because the accounting differences
are relevant and if one were to include
a the whole derivatives exposure without
netting which is uh prevailing in the US
the figures would look much less the
similar than they look
today we are we've been reflecting on
Leverage ratios and uh there is there
are there is certainly something to say
in favor of uh being of being on the
strict side than on the on the on the
sort of L Lux
side however we should also be aware
that two strict leverage ratios do have
an impact on
liquidity and uh on especially on the
so-called low yields low return
activities which often are the ones that
provide liquidity to a variety of
markets
more
specifically uh what banks would do if
uh if uh with a leverage ratio that
would be too binding they would for
example shed out the low yield activity
for example the repo
markets so the the we have to I'm saying
this because we have to be uh careful in
assessing the impact of different
leverage ratios on markets that are
essential for monetary policy essential
for a variety of reasons but our markets
that and that provide ample liquidity to
all the important essential activities
but are also markets where the rate of
risk of return are relatively low and we
got to make sure leverage ratios are not
going to destroy these
markets and uh and therefore limiting
the number of counterparties for a
variety of
transactions we are we are seriously
thinking about about this issue but it's
not
uh it's not as um as simple as uh as we
thought until not long ago so we we
don't have a view exactly on what is the
the 3% of the Basel committee certainly
allows for ample uh ample um
consideration of the present leverage
ratios incidentally there are banks in
the Euro area which also have a leverage
ratio even lower than
3% do you plan to issue a policy paper
on
that we do we no we don't have yet this
on our on
our on our agenda for next year but we
certainly take note of this and we will
reflect on this in the next in the next
board
meeting actually the next steering
committee meeting which comes
before if I may intervene here I mean
the parliament has some skepti ility in
some quarters on the risk weights
largely because politician are very good
at fiddling around with some of the
largest asset classes of uh risk weights
uh you know in in the sense of mortgages
Sovereign bonds lending and and we've
gone and fiddled with it in in in crd4
and that's not really uh then a proper
risk weight in in that sense and surely
netting is a little bit of arithmetic um
but but more seriously when we were
looking at this when we were doing crd4
we saw scope for there to be different
Leverage
applicable to different business models
or indeed maybe even looking internally
of a bank uh that the leverage within uh
different sectors which might help to
overcome the problem of of what do you
do with those that are are otherwise
going to be chopped if you just have it
as a blanket thing across especially a
hole of a universal Bank you could say
right different sectors of it have to
stay within different anyway I just say
that that's some of where we got with
our discussions
you you see one one of the um one of the
beauties of the leverage ratio is that
it's a simple concept that people
understand and uh it is a concept that
doesn't need to play around with risk
weights so that is that's the that's the
good thing it's quite clear and it says
something if we if I understood uh if we
start uh having different leverage
ratios across different activities then
we got to be careful about that or aware
that you could have Arbitrage of placing
different Assets in order to minimize
the effect op let's call it optimize the
effect on the leverage ratio so I think
it's interesting but but we got to be we
we may risk losing the attractiveness of
having a simple concept that disregards
the choices of the banks
management thank you uh now for the ECR
Ashley
Fox thank you Mr dry you referred in
your opening statement to solvency 2 and
I'd like to ask you three questions on
that I've had the pleasure of following
that dossier for more than four years
now so I share your desire that this be
concluded as swiftly as
possible on the legislation itself can I
ask you to comment upon whether you you
think it is desirable for the European
Parliament and the council to be
legislating in the detail that it is or
would you in fact prefer the finer
points of detail to be decided by the
regulator in particular do you think
it's appropriate for us to be saying
what percentage of certain classes of
assets should be held by insurers or in
fact is that something that Regulators
should decide and by writing it into
legislation be creating risks for the
future secondly what risks do you
believe there are that when we Implement
solvency 2 we will adversely affect the
amount of investment in infrastructure
projects that's a concern of many
members who are working on this
legislation and does that create a risk
for the European
economy my third Point relates to the
use of credit ratings
in CRA
3 uh we we said the parliament said that
all references in EU Lord credit ratings
for regulatory purposes should be phased
out by the beginning of
2020 and yet in solvency 2 we're busy
writing into law more references to
credit
ratings so I'd like your view on this do
you think that's a sensible thing for
the parliament to be doing and do you
think that in fact these specific
specific references to credit ratings
within solvency 2 could in fact increase
Risk by which I'm referring to the cliff
Edge effect if we say insurers can't
invest in anything that's below Triple B
are we in fact storing up problems in
the future thank
you thank
you the uh what is the optimal mix
between a detailed legislation and
regulators
discretion it's uh it's pretty clear now
from uh from um another variety of other
issues that uh if we let the regulator
to
be completely free we end up
having regulatory
Arbitrage if we let if we have a
completely rigid
legislation we may have we may risk in a
manner in a in an area uh like like this
one which is subject to continuous
change we may risk obsolesence of the
legislation so where the wisdom will
place the right line is a difficult
issue the ideal thing would be to limit
the regulator's
discretion and at the same time have
legislation that can be easily adapted
to the various varying
circumstances we are moving towards in
all other areas we are moving towards
however we should keep in mind in all
other areas we are moving towards a
more uniform harmonized system so to
behave differently in the solvency 2
would in a sense run against what is the
general tendency of financial regulation
in recent times
on your second point is if if solvency 2
reduces insurers ability to provide
long-term financing to the
economy well we don't have evidence to
this extent for the time being insurers
continue to invest medium
longterm and uh their investment policy
is driven by the need to match
liabilities and assets
duration
the signs that insurers move to
long-term and liquid investment to take
advantage of higher rates of return in
the current environment of low interest
rates are
there so we believe that none of these
arguments is used in the short-term
discussions on the long-term guarantee
package to obtain Capital relief
concessions I think that's another
dimension that we should we should keep
in
mind
um you also asked where we have a view
on
whether the should have
a risk
weights by set by by the uh legislator
on aop I think I've answered this
question what what what else I'm sorry
what else ratings and whether it's
appropriate for us to be putting
specific references to credit ratings in
soleny 2 omnibus 2 when we've only just
passed CRA 3 saying that such references
should be phased out I mean do you think
this is useful and appropriate to
include those references in this
legislation we we have we have really
haven't thought to this
yet so we will certainly report to you
as soon as we've gone through
this thank
you Meanwhile we're building in a triple
B threshold which many sovereigns can't
even reach at the moment so um uh that's
going to be interesting in a little
while um right for the GU now nichos
chtis thank you madam chair
president roughly two months
ago I asked you what your assessment
was of what are
called red credit red loans in Greece
and I asked you
whether the 50
billion for recapitalization of banks if
that was not sufficient what were you
going to do two months have gone by and
uh I won't ask any new questions I'll
simply repeat that question I asked you
two months ago you said at the time that
you were just as concerned about these
loans these red loans and that you
weren't very concerned however about the
health of the Greek system and I'd like
to know whether you have any more
information for us today secondly
related a question related to your
office the importance of these red loans
in the balance sheets of Greek
Banks do they represent a systemic risk
for Greece or for other Europe Euro area
countries and finally I would like to
know whether the supervision carried out
today by the Bank of Greece of uh bank's
balance sheets shows if it shows that
the amount that you have set aside for
this is not going to be sufficient how
do you plan to save the banks how do you
intend to do
this well we never discussed the
specific point of these type of loans at
the s are
being and um let me say that if we are
not at the point in time when we want to
discuss further financing needs for
Greece uh we had the program that runs
at the end of 2014 we had the IMF
program which runs until
2016 so I don't think it's yet the time
to say what if the money is not
enough on the specific loow lo I as I
said we haven't discussed it in the
SRB and on this you asked me also a
question about the supervision of Bank
of
Greece I um could I ask you to repeat
the
question yes I'm quite happy to do that
I understand that
um this uh meeting has been going on for
quite a long time my point was
in the case that the supervision
exercised by the Bank of Greece and by
the ECB shows that these red loans are a
problem for the bank's B balance
sheets and uh blackwat is doing the same
investigation and if it emerges at the
50 billion is not sufficient I'd like to
know what do you plan to do are you
going to discuss this with the bank of
Greece or are you doing
that no at the present time we haven't
really faced this problem and as I said
what to do we'll have to see at the
present time resources are enough in uh
as the program
foresees finish yes
okay right thank you uh and now uh for
the EP ver
Lang yeah president is uh
yes Mr President I wasn't really sure if
I understood you correctly concerning
the money market
funds and the commission's proposed
regulation on Shadow
banking would you agree with the
council's
proposal that
um funds with um flexible payouts should
be banned in favor of those with uh uh
3% cash
buffered now you mentioned risks about
Clearing Houses
ccbs I think when you look at the uh
extent of derivatives
worldwide The netting in the United
States is much more risky than the
possible problems caused by CCP if I
remember correctly it was on the 15th of
September
1.27% of risks were covered by
derivatives on the balance sheets of
American Banks uh because of this
netting and nothing had to be
proved you
said that
the
responsible uh body is making
proposals
now what do you think about companies
that are used by companies derivatives
are used by
companies and my third
question it's already been raised
cooperation with the basil
committee the zero assessment in uh
assessment of uh State bonds this has
already been
addressed by the Basel committee is it
possible over the long term that this
risk assessment of zero for Sovereign
bonds would gradually move towards a
more realistic assessment and that this
would resolve some problems in the long
term thank you the well on on the on the
money market funds I I did say for what
we think about this and uh so uh I said
that the
Cavs should be subject to the same
regulatory provision as Banks or
legislation should provide for their
compulsory conversion into variable net
assets
vavs so um I think I did say enough and
uh the I think there is some room for
improvement as Madame chair has said
with respect to the proposal
uh on the uh
derivatives we um one of
the in a sense best de developments of
the work that has taken place after the
financial crisis was the fact that all
the standard
derivatives contracts would be cleared
through
ccps and um the data would be stored
with trade
repositories
the non for the nonstandard derivatives
there would be separate clearing but
with more punitive Capital
requirements now it's turning out that
uh even though
the even though the
process uh is uh is
continuing uh it's turning out that it's
actually at at world at worldwide level
to be more difficult than uh than all of
us had expected especially you since you
are the Emy
raor so I think we've got to continue
working on this with these two uh sides
two angles maximum
transparency on one hand and on the
other we should address the fact that
the ccps
could become source of systemic
risk
we thanks to Amir a new set of granular
data will be available in Europe it will
be collected by trade repositories made
available by them to
esma the National authorities and also
the
SRB so thanks to EMR this will permit to
study what type of exposure
concentrations and possible contagion
effects are
developing I think the SRB has a task to
warn and recommends to all authorities
at European and National
level also creates through its normal
operations a dialogue Forum involving
all of them on a permanent
basis and uh the SRB as uh you you know
very well will be asked under Emir to
give macroprudential views on
procyclicality and interoperability as
I've said in my introductory
speech on the um indeed very difficult
question on um risk
weights uh during
the uh last General board meeting on
September 19th a group of experts
including from Academia presented a
technical report on this topic to the
srbs general
board we had what I would uh still
Define a very rich fruitful
discussion it's uh the discussion
concluded that this report is a good
starting point to better understand the
risks arising from Sovereign
exposures and how these risks could be
mitigated but there is no ESRB POC
policy action
foreseen in response to this
work there is neither an ESRB warning or
recommendation envisaged nor are there
any formal step being
considered we will continue working on
this topic however with a view to
publishing a
report of scientific
nature and I'll Sly inform the this
committee about any progress in this
area in due time however I expect that
this will not happen before the SSM ECB
balance sheet assessment and stress test
have been
completed so thank you okay thank you
okay thank you very much uh and thank
you very much it's a it's a long time to
answer questions for for 3 hours so uh
uh thank you very much and and thank you
for the information that you've given us
thank you thank you thank you and we'll
see you again before too long absolutely
thank
[Applause]
you so that's it until tomorrow at 9:
f
be
for